yes so one of the things I want to touch
on is this whole idea of there's tons of
miners who are mining but they don't
sell 100% of the Bitcoin to pay for
electricity do you have any sense of the
percentages that certain miners are
having to sell and then how that changes
with price fluctuations as well right
are there certain kind of in those tiers
you described some that to sell 100
percent to fund operations and some that
are maybe selling only ten percent and
then if you kind of back into the larger
miners probably have lower cost power
you can really start to understand how
much of the cell pressure on a daily
basis is coming from miners or is that
just too many unknown variables and
therefore difficult to to come up with
right now no that's a great question in
our report we model all that out we have
these large tables in the research
report these Excel tables and that's
exactly what we're doing
we understand how much electricity is
being consumed by each layer based on
their margins so if you're running a 17
ad at six cents you might be consuming
$80 worth of electricity per month and
you may be making 120 in revenue so you
know that you have to sell $80 of your
once wine which is at least 7075 percent
right no 66 percent right so their
margins are 33% and they have to sell 66
percent of their electricity if they're
at for example 6 cents and then if
they're had five sons maybe they only
have to sell 50% and if there are three
sons they only have to sell 30% and yes
that's what's key and you know you
brought that up and that's what's so
helpful for the network when these when
these miners who are operating almost at
breakeven you'd have to sell 80 to 100
percent of their Bitcoin blowout and now
their Bitcoin is getting allocated to
these efficient miners who only have to
sell 30% while they're holding more
Bitcoin cell pressure comes off the
network um you know people a lot of
people think that Bitcoin trades a
couple billion a day that's what's
important that's inaccurate a majority
of that is fake Asian trading its
algos it's it's a day
trading that just creates short-term
volatility what moves the price of of an
asset is net Fiat in and net Fiat out
and that's what and and more interested
in the intermediate it's a long term
right so I'm interested in what's net
money in net money out miners are
bringing net money out because they
they're getting your Bitcoin and they're
selling it to fund electricity now
demand and positive sentiment is what
brings funds and Hodler is to bring new
cash in and we think and and that
counterbalance is miners sell pressure
now that miners cell pressure will get
reduced when inefficient miners are
operating at their breakeven or below
breakeven they have to shut off and now
their Bitcoin is going to the miners who
only have to sell 10 or 20% of their
Bitcoin to fund electricity and that's
how you get these better environments
for Bitcoin of rally we're gonna
experience that we just got a taste we
just had that large difficulty
adjustment that was a bunch of old
generation equipment getting wiped out
once we go through the having revenue is
gonna get cut in half all the old
generation equipment for the most part
is going to shut off you know markets
most mark markets are supposed to be one
of the most efficient price discounts in
mechanisms right future discounting
mechanisms I think in equity markets the
larger the market the more efficient
right crypto markets are probably one of
the less efficient markets out there but
there's there's still efficiencies so we
think we think we think a lot of the s
nines are going to shut off but some of
them are gonna flow to areas in the
world that just have the cheapest power
or subsidized power it's like pouring a
bottle of water at the top of a mountain
it's gonna go to the lowest point that's
it's that's how that's how gravity and
water works these s nines are gonna flow
to areas like Venezuela they're gonna
float areas like Iran Kazakhstan where
there's subsidized power or near zero
power or low flow to areas where where a
utility has excess power
and and they Mikan they'll be smart
enough to get involved we have clients
capturing the natural gas then they're
running at 1 cent power that's gonna be
a boom in the US are the group that
we're working with is a is a steel mill
and and and some of their jobs are
getting repurposed to Bitcoin mining
there's I mean I mean the revolution
that's going to happen with with Bitcoin
mining is about power that's the most
important component so those who have
the cheapest power in the world are
going to start getting involved in this
they already are and then just make this
our network more credible and more
secure because you have these you have
Bitcoin you know our belief is Bitcoin
is a commodity and it's infancy and and
when you get a better release of the
supply you get less volatility and it
becomes more usable right and bitcoin is
just it's it's ten years old it's a it's
it's a commodity in its infancy you look
at oil gold soybeans all the suppliers
are they're the ones controlling the
supply and they kind of influence price
well they hatch out 12 months right were
there futures contracts and they're and
they're forwards
you know Cargill Barrett gold Aramco
they all have 20 man trade desks hedging
out the product with Bitcoin mining it's
a Chinese farmer it's some small farm
small farm in the US and and and when
Bitcoin starts to sell off they might
puke their coin and they're exacerbating
the prices in Bitcoin and they're
they're the suppliers so once this
becomes more institutionalized once we
get better products which is happening
right in our face right see any has
their future now we have options we're
witnessing Bitcoin becoming more mature
and when this supply gets released
smoother and volatility gets sucked out
more it becomes a better store of value
and it becomes a better digital bulb I
mean if oil was just fluctuating like
crazy it is I mean most that people
don't realize commodities are some of
the most volatile assets
so you want to point to Bitcoin talk
about volatility I mean oil was at 150
in 2009 2010 and now it's hit $20 so
there you go a lot it's lost 85 percent
right so we think there's a lot of
things that are happening right now that
just make us very bullish Bitcoin um to
come out anything is a bit of a tangent
but but Bitcoin is 10 years old it's a
commodity in its infancy the difference
is no matter what the supply gets
released
that's code but but the people that are
going to influence the supply won't
become far far more diligent about how
its released we're gonna have better
exchanges we're gonna have derivative
products they're gonna start using
better schedules for treasury management
volatility will get sucked out and it's
going to be a more usable digital gold
because volatility gets sucked out and
and now people are going to use it for
its it and most importantly it's all
happening right in front of our face